I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance what do we do now this evil
is unfolding like it or not it can
unfold and you can lie there or it can
unfold and you can resist there are
practical means things you can do I
intend to offer some in each volume of
this new series and we start with
something you can accomplish by not
doing it is a week we were asked to give
him a chance this is how he has wasted
that chance 33 hours after Hillary
Clinton's concession just had a very
open and successful presidential
election now professional protesters
incited by the media are protesting very
unfair the morning he was to announce
his first staff appointments Wow the New
York Times is losing thousands of
subscribers because of their very poor
and highly inaccurate coverage of the
Trump phenomenon
the New York Times sent a letter to
their subscribers apologizing for their
bad coverage of me I wonder if it will
change doubt it the New York Times
states today the djt believes more
country should acquire nuclear weapons
how dishonest they are I never said this
68 days until his inauguration still
bitching about his paranoid fantasies
about the media still lying about what
he said during the campaign still
referring to himself in the third person
still obsessing over one newspaper as if
he were 15 and it had refused to go with
him to the junior prom give him a chance
what in the hope that he will someday
grow up enough to be able to see over
the top of the oval office desk we do
not have time for the White House
edition of Celebrity Apprentice starring
president-elect [ __ ] grabber give him a
chance because we're all supposed to
pretend that this is a normal man and
that was a normal election because we're
all supposed to forget that the Russians
interfered with the election and the
involvement of the FBI at minimum
affected the outcome because we're all
going to follow the Washington Post and
call them populist s' instead of white
supremacists even though they are white
supremacists give him a chance all we
are saying is give fascism a chance who
knows it might not be as bad as we think
it might not be a bottomless
hit this is not my president and judging
by the margin by which Hillary Clinton
won the popular vote at this rate it
will be larger than Kennedy over Nixon
in 1960 this is not America's president
either and so we will resist each
statement of substance or policy or
intent will be met with one of
resistance each action and events staged
by this man who lost the popular vote
will be matched with protests by that
resistance each politician whom he
fooled with the charm from one of his
other personalities from the banana
Republicans already lining up to lick
his boots to the Democrats like this
Fathead Joe Manchin will be rejected by
that resistance so it's no democratic or
liberal politician has yet stepped
forward out of the morass of politics
Inc to take on the responsibility of the
resistance I with complete awareness of
the presumptuousness and arrogance of
this statement volunteer myself and I
will gladly turn over all these burdens
to any more legitimate and informed
lawmaker or political or cultural leader
who has the guts to take these burdens I
do not want violence I'm not proposing
the overthrow of the government by any
means other than legal and political I
think protests should be limited to
Washington
Trump Tower and the Trump hotels I have
no pie-in-the-sky plan to have the
Electoral College alter the outcome
somehow I will even acquiesce to a
president Pence just get this man out of
here and I will repeat what I said last
week this Trump is a profoundly and
proactively self-destructive individual
it is now our sacred duty to help him
finish his self-destruction if it is
going to be him destroyed at his own
hands or democracy destroyed at his own
hands it is going to be him and the
first step is to complete the deal Ajith
amaizing of his presidency and his
election D legitimizing that he himself
began who said the opinion polling was
rigged who said the election itself was
rigged
who refused to say whether he would
honor the outcome of that election why
the president-elect did and he is the
president election we're supposed to
give him a chance we're supposed to
believe him fine I'll give him a chance
I believe what he said I'll take his
word for it the polling was rigged
the election was rigged and he is not
bound to honor the outcome of the vote
and neither are we oh and I'll also take
his word for it about the electoral
college
not his backfilling cover-your-ass tweet
from yesterday about its genius nor its
companion boast which proves he will
never get over being a president who
lost the popular vote that if there were
no electoral college he would have
simply won bigger no his tweets from the
night of November 6 2012 when Big
Brother Trump thought Barack Obama would
win the electoral college vote but lose
the popular he lost the popular vote by
a lot and on the election we should have
a revolution in this country the phony
Electoral College made a laughingstock
out of our nation the loser won we can't
let this happen we should march on
Washington and stop this travesty our
nation is totally divided let's fight
like hell and stop this great and
disgusting injustice the world is
laughing at us more votes equals a loss
revolution the election is a total sham
and a travesty we are not a democracy
our our country is now in serious and
unprecedented trouble like never before
those tweets the president-elect deleted
that night but one other one is still
alive on his account at last check the
Electoral College is a disaster for a
democracy a disaster for a democracy
let's fight like hell and stop this
great and disgusting injustice more
votes equals a loss revolution so saith
the almighty Trump whatever you wish sir
you asked for it resist peace